hey youtubers its charlie Thank You
everybody that left me questions on my
North remembers storyline video lots of
questions about characters interacting
like old characters that have been
separated meeting back up I definitely
think there are some stark characters
that might run into each other again but
I don't think a lot of that's gonna
happen to like the very very end I think
people are gonna remain relatively
separated George are Martin actually
said this really interesting thing a
couple years ago where he was like you
know when the story starts you have all
these characters that are in really
close proximity like like the stark
children and then they scatter to the
four winds and then at a certain point
as the story reaches its climax and you
start moving towards the finale all
these storylines start to converge on
each other by the final act of the play
you know however you want to think about
it obviously that's a long ways off
because we have at least like eight
seasons but just careful for spoilers as
we get into questions if you haven't
caught up on season 5 first question
here we go Korey asks a few families
would be good but if they overdo it they
run the real risk of either skimming
over too many characters or getting
bogged down in explanations yeah the
internet definitely hates exposition but
they'll probably end up doing is
bringing on one or two new northern
Lords and then just using the existing
ones they've already established on the
show that means at least Starks Bolton's
car starts and umbers I do hope we see
the manderlys at some point but I think
at the very least we'll at least get
some more umbers some new um birds that
we haven't seen before like small John
as much as people get upset about them
cutting stuff out of the books
I think there'd be more rage if they did
a book storyline but it ended up being
terrible because they tried to do too
much like if they tried to cram the
AEGON storyline in season six they'd
have less time to spend in King's
Landing with what's going on with Cersei
less time to spend in the north with the
North remembers storyline less time with
Arya in the east I'm actually really
interested to see I know they're doing a
spin-off TV series but I'm interested to
see if they try to do like a comic
spin-off like they did with Buffy like
they did Buffy Season 9 in the comics
where they just they continued
storylines that they didn't have time
for on the TV show would you guys
actually read a game of Thrones comic
book that's just based on stuff that
happens on the show that they had to cut
out of the books
next question Apollo asks I really want
the show to catch up with bran Stark
from the books and seeing Rick and stark
emerge as a military genius like his
brother Rob would be interesting well I
mean I don't know if I'd call Rob a
military genius he was definitely really
good he had some big victories but
Rickon is so young that he's kind of
like a sweet Robin
character where it's like we hope he
turns into something eventually but
right now I mean this is gonna take at
least like six or seven years before he
gets to Geoffrey's age where he can
actually sit and make decisions
remember when maester Lewin was helping
brand make decisions at Winterfell
because bran had to deal with the
business of the north wall rob was off
fighting his war Rickon taking power
would be kind of like that
next question Chad asks I'd like to see
the crannogmen decided to deal with the
phrase in the mountain clans gather up
to go deal with the Bolton's we're just
talking about the crannogmen they'd
actually be the closest to deal with the
phrase because the twins are like right
down there
I definitely think we'll see evil turn
on itself Walder Frey not a good person
very paranoid very quick to switch
allegiances the implication back in
season 3 was that all it took for him to
help the Lannisters out was the slight
that Rob dealt them when he married
Talisa / Walder Frey's daughter so I
don't think it'd be too hard for
Littlefinger to find a way to stir up
some trouble between the phrase and the
Lannisters and the Bolton's he's already
playing the Lannisters against the
Bolton's right now maybe even eventually
with some help from the Tyrells too
because he's been wheeling and dealing
with the Queen of thorns since before
the purple wedding next question
Aiden asks what are the spiders the
White Walkers are depicted writing those
are just ice spiders they supposedly
came out of the long night we don't know
where they came from or how they rose
they're just like another species that
the White Walkers have co-opted they
could be creatures that the White
Walkers twisted with their magic or they
could have already just naturally grown
that way they could be a race of eye
spiders that just naturally evolved in
the far north the horses that they're
writing are normal horses that died and
then they raised as White's next
question Jabez asks I want to see
Brienne versus Ramsay I want to watch
bran punch Ramsay in the dick and then
beat his head in with a rock like she
did to cook Ain well I don't know about
Brienne crossing paths with Ramsay she
is in the north right now relatively
close to Winterfell I'm hoping that she
stays there but she could go further
south just because I'm hoping her
storyline does more stuff from her book
story like they they've diverged from
her book story quite a bit in season 5
it does seem like season 6 is doing a
lot of book things that they've skipped
over in the past Ironborn is like the
best example of that so we might see
some Brienne gravedigger action if you
don't know what the gravedigger theory
is I'll add a link in the description
I've already done a video about that but
I'm not expecting Brienne to cross paths
with Ramsay it's totally possible though
it's really hard to tell what they're
gonna change from the books next
question
aditya asks if bran has acquired
greensight the
you know everything that's going on with
aria John and Sansa and can't he see
into the future well the thing about
greensight is is that there are some
limitations he can really only see in
and around weirwood trees so unless
something happened near a weirwood tree
he's probably not gonna know about it
that becomes really problematic when
you're talking about the far south we're
not as many weirwood trees grow way way
back in the ancient history of Westeros
weirwood trees grew all over the place
but a lot of them were cut down by the
first men then the Andals and now like
for instance Stannis there was a
weirwood tree inside Dragonstone Stannis
cut it down and Melisandre burned it so
anyway there's a weirwood tree branch
can see what that weirwood tree like the
face on it has seen so yes brain can see
things but only things there in
proximity to weirwoods and because the
weirwoods haven't seen the future no I
don't think that he's going to be seeing
through the future most of what he sees
will be the past that's what people mean
when they talk about weirwood flashbacks
it's just another storytelling device
that the show might end up using at a
certain point the Searcy flashback was a
little bit different in that it was a
POV flashback it was Cersei remembering
something
next question Rory asks on the show how
his little finger able to be offered the
title warden to the north when he
doesn't possess land in the north well
regardless of what protocol dictates I
think he's able to extract anything that
he can get out of Cersei like sir she's
willing to give up anything to get what
she wants
under normal circumstances if he wanted
to become warden of the north he would
probably try to acquire that title via
marriage but I think in the context of
the show what would happen is is that
Sansa would take the title wardeness of
the north he would marry her to sweet
Robin so that he would gain control over
both those lands because he'd have
influence over sweet Robin because he's
kind of a weak willed person and he has
influence with Sansa although given what
she's endured in season five I don't
know how friendly she's gonna be when
she sees Littlefinger again she might
hate the out of him right now for
making her marry Ramsay next question
bogdan asks if the north has so many
houses how is it possible that Robb
Stark only raised an army of 18,000 men
and reached like 50 or 60,000
Lannister's and about 40,000 after surge
ami was defeated I never understood how
Robb had such a small army
r.i.p well the problem with the north is
is that like just in terms of
geographical area it's the biggest but
its population is the lowest like a lot
more people live further south so
there's just more
people to be had from the lords in the
south you also have to consider that of
the Great Houses in the north
you know whenever Robb Stark tries to
raise an army goes around and he asked
for men some of the Lords are more loyal
than others so some are more willing to
give of their resources but really it
just gets down to total population like
the total population of the North
dramatically lower than some of the
places in the south that are
geographically smaller thank you
everybody for so many questions we're
getting closer to that Dunkin egg book
coming out and I'm talking to like a
couple other sponsor people about
beefing up some of my giveaways so if
that ends up happening I'll let you guys
know because it'll just mean I may be
able to give more swag away
congratulations to the winner of this
week's giveaway Harry Johnson you and a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info there's a
bunch of other stuff happening this week
so be sure to check my Facebook and
Twitter for updates on when videos are
posting all of the links for that stuff
in the description but we have like
agents of shield is starting Gotham is
already back heroes is here there's a
Walking Dead finale there's a whole
bunch of awesome stuff going on and
everything is actually pretty good so
far
agents of shield for instance supposed
to be like a whole different show now
almost like the season 3 premiere
tomorrow will be a completely new pilot
like the show's not gonna look anything
like it did in season 1 and 2 so why
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here to learn all about the
gravedigger theory if you don't know
anything about that and you can click
here to catch up on Gotham before
tonight thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight